and what's so scary right now with the
left
is that this guy raphael warnock is
extraordinarily
radical in his leftism but even the
left-wing
establishment even the people who would
be considered in the center
in the mainstream of the liberal
establishment
or pushing unthinkably radical
ideas i think of somebody like bill
gates does it get more establishment
than bill gates
he is a typical left-wing
billionaire liberal guy who's always
trying to
involve himself in public policy bill
gates
was just on jake tapper's show on cnn
why i couldn't possibly tell you
he was asked about the lockdown what
should happen this remember we had 15
days to slow the spread
back in march now we're 9 or 10 months
later for some reason this is still
going on
and bill gates brought on
says well what are we gonna do
unfortunately
probably another four to six months at
least of shutting everything down
well certainly mask wearing uh has
essentially no downside they're not
expensive
bars and restaurants in most of the
country will be closed as we go into
this wave and i think
sadly that's appropriate depending on
how severe it is
the decision about schools is much more
complicated
as a general rule whenever bill gates
has
an opinion about politics you can assume
that the opposite is the thing we ought
to do
bill gates is notoriously infamously
ignorant of political prudence
and the ideas that he does have about
politics are really
terrible i mean wicked bad ideas
now here he just says okay we need to
shut down businesses for another four to
six months because
we haven't put every every small
business out in this country
and so we got another four to six months
that'll really do the trick
since it's too bad but look that's just
what we have to do there's no downside
to wearing masks
there's no doubt i could name a lot of
downsides one were social animals
uh we're supposed to see one another
it's nice to see a smile uh
we are supposed to breathe the fresh air
uh you can't do that with a mask
we're supposed to speak one of the uh
defining features of humanity is that we
have speech when you put that mask over
you you are
you are literally putting a muzzle on
yourself now but be
because bill gates is a technocratic
liberal
he's not taking political or ethical or
philosophical
uh considerations into his thought here
because he's he just accepts all of the
liberal premises about the world some of
which are contradictory so he just
he just wants to talk about what works
there's no downside i think there are a
lot of downsides to the masks
he's even admitting by saying that right
maybe there's not a lot of upside that's
the implication
but look there's no downside of course
there's a lot of downside one of the
other
downsides of course is that we're told
if people wear the masks we can all
return to normal and i said from the
very beginning that's complete bs
the masks are not going to calm people
down they're going to whip people up
into a frenzy because the masks are a
symbol that we're in the midst of this
terrible unprecedented pandemic we've
never had
masking such as this before certainly
not in our lifetimes and really not ever
at this scale so just to see the mask
is not to say okay we can return to
normal it's to say we're not even close
to normal and we're not going to be
back to normal until we take the mask
off which i think is a large part of the
the political symbolism of the masks but
then
he goes a little further it's not just
four to six months and you'll notice a
lot of big business guys are all for the
lockdowns
because the lockdowns have caused an uh
historic amount of money to be shifted
from small businesses
to large businesses like amazon apple
all these sorts of online uh google all
these sorts of online companies
but it's more than four to six months it
might be over a year
certainly by the summer we'll be
way closer to normal than we are now but
even through early 2022 unless we help
other countries get rid of this disease
and we get high vaccination rates in our
country
the risk of reintroduction will be there
and of course
the global economy will be uh slowed
down which hurts
america economically in a pretty
dramatic way
so we'll have starting the summer about
nine months where a few things like big
public gatherings
uh will still be restricted but
you know we can see now that somewhere
between 12 to 18 months
and we have a chance if we manage it
well to get back to normal
just a quick question i guess i'm a
little confused here who appointed bill
gates to
run all of our public policy for us why
is bill gates is not saying we should do
this we ought to do this hey i'd like to
persuade my fellow citizens to do this
he's saying this is what we will do this
is what we are going to do
because bill gates is one of these
masters of the universe
who influences public policy in enormous
ways
he's saying this is what's going to
happen bill gates
is a great avatar of the kind of liberal
establishment the liberal
political bureaucratic technic
obviously technological entertainment
media
establishment the blob as we refer to it
and bill gates is a key figure in that
he holds all the politically correct
views
and they're they're pretty radical you
know he's a dorky guy who wears a
sweater so he doesn't seem that radical
but in many ways his views are more
radical than than even someone like
raphael warnock
in many ways the liberal establishment's
views are more radical than the woke
radicals
there are a lot of crazy conspiracy
theories going around the internet about
bill gates
of course this is according to the media
crazy wild conspiracy theories that bill
gates is interested
for instance in population control that
he
he doesn't want uh p especially in the
third world
uh people to have babies and so he's
going he's very involved in ways to
limit the growth of the population
and i think these these conspiracy
theories are so crazy in order to
believe these kooky crazy conspiracy
theories
you would have to listen to bill gates
himself well the population growth issue
at the global level is not that daunting
that is
the population percentage-wise is
growing slower today
than in the past and so it
will actually peak out the problem is
that the population is growing the
fastest where
people are less able to deal with it so
it's in the very
poorest places that you're going to have
a tripling
in population by 2050 and so their
ability to feed
educate provide jobs stability
protect the environment in those
locations mean
you know they're faced with an almost
impossible problem northern nigeria
yemen
chad and so what we need to do
is take this aid generosity in this
innovation and go into those places
offer the women better tools where they
want to
space birthing or have a smaller family
size
and improve health because it's
amazingly as
children survive parents feel like
they'll have enough kids to support them
in their old age and so they choose
to have less children this
point of view that bill gates is pushing
is morally abhorrent it is
evil it is wicked and he's been pushing
it fanatically for decades
he is trying to make sure that there are
fewer babies
born specifically fewer little black
babies in africa
and fewer little brown babies in the
third world that's not an exaggeration
he has been foisting abortion on
countries that are traditionally opposed
to abortion
foisting contraception on countries that
are traditionally opposed to
contraception
these ideas of a sort of sterilized
society for a very long time
in 2009 this sounds like something out
of a science fiction movie
there was a secret meeting held between
bill gates
george soros i know we're not allowed to
say his name but george soros
oprah winfrey a number of other
left-wing
establishment billionaires warren
buffett was there you can google it i
mean
it was a secret meeting except it did
leak to the press and it garnered
substantial press
attention at that time all of it was
designed
around this issue of overpopulation
so we were told overpopulation is a
terrible problem this is all based on
the crackpot theories
of a scientist a stanford scientist
named paul ehrlich
from the 1970s ehrlich published a book
first in 1968 and then it was
republished later on
called the population bomb it said
absolutely the world population now it
was
at that time was around 3.5 billion and
we're going to have mass starvation
mass death in the 1970s and 1980s it's
guaranteed to happen
the only question now is can we
sterilize people and coerce abortions
enough
to to limit some of that misery and
actually advocated
not just getting people voluntarily to
do this sort of thing but
advocated governments coercing that as a
result of these crackpot theories
you had indira gandhi in the prime
minister of
india start tying water and access to
electricity and
access to medical care and and ration
cards to
uh sterilization so the sterilized
population you had china adopt the one
child policy
which caused upwards of 100 million
babies to be killed
through abortion absolutely wicked some
of the worst atrocities committed in
human history
because of these crackpots stupid
theories which were not true
the scientific expert paul ehrlich who
was a sort of neo-malthusian to use the
technical term referring to a scientist
from centuries ago named malthus who had
the same
overpopulation fascination uh it just
wasn't true
since the 19th the world population has
doubled you go from about three and a
half billion to seven billion
or eight billion or obviously growing
still and
world hunger is at an all-time low it
just
didn't happen and these these
moral perverts like like bill gates and
other people pushing this politically
correct moral standard
which is utterly opposed to human life
which says that it to use uh
paul ehrlich's term that the births of
all these babies
is a cancer that needs to be cut out
these guys are pushing this view despite
evidence to the contrary these brilliant
experts
these eggheads these people who are
focused on data in science
and the liberal standard you know i
don't know i mean i'm sure there are
some kind of
actual crackpot theories about bill
gates but you've just heard it in his
own words but he's just i can't imagine
anything worse than that
that is what the scientific
establishment
is telling you and it's because they
maybe they know something or
a thing or two about science probably
they don't guys like paul ehrlich
maintained their professorship at
stanford continued to win lots of
prestigious awards
even though his central thesis was wrong
and led to untold human misery
and they certainly know nothing about
morality or even
a political prudence and the left is
pushing this from the establishment